What did you decide on, David?
>> So for the first sentence,
my background knowledge tells me that
the numbers 3 and 5 aren't objects.
They aren't destinations, they aren't
locations, they aren't targets.
They're just numbers.
Of all these frames,
the only one that's looking for
just numbers is the frame, to subtract.
So I choose take8 as the meaning for
the first sentence.
So for the second sentence, my
background knowledge tells me first that
I'm an agent, that my briefcase is an
object, and that work is a destination.
So if I then try to map those three
things to their various different
categories here, I find that
the only one that works is take2.
I am an agent, my briefcase is
an object, and work is a destination.
So the third sentence a good
bit more complicated.
I still know that I am an agent, I know
that the casino is a place of business,
and the $5 million could be
considered a prize or an object.
So that gets me down to take6 or take7.
Take6 is to steal, take7 is to cheat or
swindle, which are subtly different.
But my background knowledge
of the idea of source
said that sources were usually
indicated by the preposition, from.
If I took $5 million from the casino,
then the casino would be a source.
But I don't have from in
front of the casino here, so
I'm not going to regard it as a source.
Instead I'm going to go with take7.
>> That's an interesting analysis,
David.
Thank you.
First of all,
congratulations on becoming rich.
I didn't know that you were going to
become rich teaching this course.
Of course, there are several
other points to note here.
One point is that you have a lot of
background knowledge associated with
the word for, perhaps because you are a
native speaker of the English language.
Not everyone may associate the same kind
of background knowledge with for and
may not be able to disambiguate
between these two.
>> That actually gets to an underlying
element of the problem as well,
that these two meanings
are themselves very similar.
So it makes sense that it's more
difficult to disambiguate between very
similar meanings than
disambiguating between stealing and
medicating, for example.
>> Another point to note here is that
although we have been discussing about
stories that are in
the English language,
this kind of analysis
applies to all languages.
Note also that so far we have been using
sentences in the English language, but
actually this kind of analysis works in
respect to the language we are using.
So I'm originally from India and
my mother tongue is Hindi.
And we can write the sentences in Hindi,
and the same kind of analysis will
work that is working here for
the word take in English.
This raises a few questions.
Might this kind of analysis work for
translation from one language
to another language?
If the different languages have similar
kind of structures, then this analysis
might help us translate sentences from
one language to another language.
Here's another question.
Do all languages have the same kind
of structure that enables mind to
make use of the structure of the
sentences to disambiguate between verbs?
>> Feel free to take up that
discussion over on our forums,
especially if you yourself don't
speak English as a first language.
You might be particularly aware of the
different structures present in English
compared to whatever
language you speak natively.